how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder
yesterday we had a very big bomb
dropped on us deadline reported that
jonathan majors has been cast for a role
in ant-man 3 and not just
any role a very big role deadline went
on to elaborate
saying that they believed that the role
that he had been cast for
is kang the conqueror and as the day
went by and people checked with their
sources
a few people were able to confirm that
he has been cast
indeed for the role of kang the
conqueror so it looks like kang the
conqueror is officially coming to the
mcu making his debut
in ant-man 3. however there is more than
just
kang the conqueror that waits for us in
ant-man 3. as it turns out this may be
one
of the biggest marvel movies ever and
yes i am
talking about ant-man 3 i know a lot of
people thought the first two ant-man
films were a little bit underwhelming
but as it turns out ant-man 3 is going
to be
an extremely important mcu film
and in this video we'll break down who
king is how he's going to come into
ant-man 3
and how we could also see the young
avengers
modok and the fantastic four in ant-man
3 as well
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
thanos funko pop all you gotta do is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below
so a few people mentioned yesterday that
they don't exactly know too much about
kang
and don't worry i'll explain because not
only is he a
very important character in the marvel
comics universe but he's also going to
be a
huge character coming to the mcu who
will most likely be in more than just
ant-man 3.
kang is a major big bad that we're
getting in the mcu so here's what you
need to know about kang
and how he's going to be introduced in
ant-man 3. the first thing that you need
to know about kang is that he's a master
of time travel
kang has a pretty complicated story but
it's not that hard to simplify it
before he was king the conqueror he was
nathaniel richards a 31st century
scholar
and a descendant of reed richards mr
fantastic of the fantastic four and of
course we'll dive into that in just a
bit
nathaniel ends up discovering time
travel technology which was illegal to
use in his time but it was created by
the fantastic four
he ends up traveling back in time to
ancient egypt and becomes the pharaoh
rama tut
and his plan was to have en saba nur the
mutant who would go on to become
apocalypse be his heir but his plan was
cut short as the fantastic four who
ended up in his timeline
managed to stop him this infuriates
nathaniel richards then he goes forward
in time to the 20th century where he
meets dr
doom he would go on to design armor
based off of dr doom's armor and he goes
on to call himself the scarlet centurion
and he ends up taking the avengers and
pinning them against their alternate
reality selfs
he plans to get rid of the avengers and
take the timeline for himself but the
avengers managed to force him from their
timeline
he then planned to go back home to the
31st century but he ends up overshooting
it by a thousand years and he discovers
a war-torn earth and they use weapons
that they no longer understand so it
makes it simple
for him to conquer the planet he
conquers the planet and many other
planets across the galaxy and he dubs
himself
kang the conqueror however his own earth
is dying so he decides to get a newer
younger earth and that leads him to our
main timeline
now over the years in the comics kang
has gone through many different
timelines devising many different plans
to conquer many of these timelines there
are multiple
alternate versions of kang in the comics
and will most likely be in the mcu
because of doctor strange in the
multiverse of
madness but time travel is basically who
king is
and the avengers opened up time travel
in avengers in-game through
the quantum realm and this is where
ant-man 3 comes in
and how he's going to debut in ant-man
3. not a lot of people give ant-man
enough credit in avengers in-game he
is the one who brought the idea of time
travel and the ability to do it to the
avengers
sure tony was kind of working on it
before but he was only able to complete
it with the help of scott lang and the
quantum realm if it wasn't for scott
getting stuck inside of the quantum
realm
time travel would never be possible and
ant-man 3 is going to be about the
quantum realm
in ant-man and the wasp we discovered a
major city
inside of the quantum realm and it was
marvel themselves who told us to look
for it
they said that it's going to play a
major part in the future of the mcu and
we all thought it was going to appear in
avengers inn game but it didn't but now
we know it's because they were saving it
for ant-man 3.
now this city inside of the quantum
realm is widely believed to be
chronopolis it has a dome over it much
like it does in the comics and as we can
see it's a very big city
much like it is in the comics and
chronopolis is kang's
base it's his city it's his home from
this city is
where he rules every one of his realms
that he has taken over
and the fact that it sits inside of the
quantum realm makes perfect
sense the quantum realm sort of exists
in between
time from the quantum realm you can go
to any time period that you want so for
somebody who takes over timelines
like kang it's a perfect base now since
kang has been here and he has a city of
chronopolis he definitely has noticed
the avengers
using time travel in avengers in-game
and this is how he's going to come into
play in ant-man 3.
if after the events of avengers in game
there is going to be anybody who is
going to be exploring time travel
through the quantum realm it's
definitely going to be
scott lang hank pym janet van dyne and
hope especially after janet van dyne
after being trapped inside of the
quantum realm for many many years came
out with
basically having powers so this is
something that they're definitely going
to be exploring in ant-man 3. and
while doing so they will run into kang
and since kang will most likely be in
the main timeline there's a
very good chance that kang will follow
them out of the quantum realm into the
main
mcu timeline and this is where he will
start to have his beef
with the avengers if he hasn't already
at some different point in time
but this would be a perfect opportunity
to start king's hatred for the avengers
since kang already has chronopolis set
up inside of the quantum realm that
means he's most likely conquered many
different timelines
but scott lang and the avengers using
time travel in avengers in-game could
have screwed up some timelines for him
because we definitely know that they
altered
some different timelines so this is
where kang will start his hatred towards
the avengers
now as i mentioned there's a big young
avengers connection here as well it's
already been rumored and widely
speculated that ant-man 3 is also going
to set up the young avengers and the
fact that kang the conqueror is going to
be
in ant-man 3 pretty much makes it
official that the young avengers will be
set up because
a younger version of king the conqueror
is
iron lad you see iron lad is actually
the person who
forms the young avengers nathaniel
richards gets hospitalized while he's a
kid
and the future king the conqueror tries
to prevent this event from happening and
this is where the young nathaniel
richards finds out about his future self
but the young nathaniel richards is
terrified of king the conqueror who he
knows he will become
so he tries to escape his destiny and he
ends up stealing his future selves
advanced armor and travels back in time
to the past and he forms
the young avengers to try and stop kang
and
they're actually successful kang ends up
dying but destroying his future self
doesn't exactly go the way that young
nathaniel richards had hoped for
by killing kang the ramifications to his
own timeline are severely affected
all of the avengers die and the young
avengers wiccan and hulkling end up
disappearing
iron lad realizes that the only way to
prevent this from happening is to go
back in time and become
king the conqueror before he goes back
in time he asks his fellow young
avengers to forgive him for his future
actions he then kisses stature
goodbye and goes back and becomes king
so not only does nathaniel richards go
on to become king the conqueror but he
also goes on to become iron lad
and as you heard me just mention he does
end up having a relationship
with stature scott lang's daughter
cassie lang
and this is the setup for the young
avengers clearly ant-man
and some others are going to run into
kang and ant-man 3. so it wouldn't make
sense for iron lad to come back in time
in an attempt to try and stop kang his
future self and that timeline that he
would go to
is our timeline here is when he will do
what he does in the comics
establish the young avengers at this
point time in the movie we would have
him who would be iron lad
cassie lang would be stature and at this
point in time wiccan and speed the two
twin boys of wanda and vision will be
grown up as well and they'll be part of
the young avengers then we have kate
bishop from the hawkeye series and it is
rumored that hulk lane is going to be a
part of the young avengers as well
and not to mention ms marvel who's
getting her very own tv show and america
chavez who is supposed to be in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness so
as it seems ant-man 3 is going to
introduce king
and the young avengers but it could also
introduce the fantastic
four as i mentioned before nathaniel
richards
is a descendant of reed richards mr
fantastic
and there's a lot of speculation going
on right now and there has been for a
pretty long time that the fantastic four
are stuck inside of the quantum realm
much like they got stuck
inside of the negative zone in the
comics and perhaps the reason that
they're stuck inside of the quantum
realm is because
kang has actually captured them and is
holding them in chronopolis
so if ant-man and the others that are
with him in ant-man 3 manage to defeat
king this could release the fantastic
four and bring them into our timeline
this will most likely be at the very end
of the movie if it happens or in a
post-credits scene but it will be a
setup for the fantastic four nonetheless
and considering the connection between
nathaniel richards and reed richards it
is a perfect opportunity
now a lot of fans were kind of
disappointed when they heard kang was
going to be the villain of ant-man 3
because they wanted
modok to be the main villain well just
because kang's coming doesn't actually
mean
that modok isn't coming as well you see
marvel is doing things a little bit
differently now they can't do the exact
same thing they did for the infinity
saga they have to be bigger they have to
be
better and it looks like their big bads
aren't going to only be in one
film they're going to be through
multiple films and kang and modok aren't
one movie villains anyways they're big
villains but the biggest thing that we
have to keep in mind
is that in ant-man and the wasp they
mentioned a mysterious
benefactor now this mysterious
benefactor slash buyer who we heard
about in ant-man and the wasp was never
revealed but we can't expect him to be
revealed
in ant-man 3. and if kang is in
chronopolis inside of the quantum realm
he is most likely not the buyer
this benefactor could be modok kang
could be the main villain but there
could be a side villain which is
modok and they could set him up to be an
even bigger villain throughout other mcu
films so for those of you worried about
modok not appearing in ant-man 3 it
doesn't necessarily mean that he's not
going to
and if marvel studios wants to bump up
the ant-man franchise a few different
levels this would be the perfect
opportunity putting kang the conqueror
some of the young avengers
iron lad modok and possibly the
fantastic four
in one movie would definitely do the
trick and i think that all of us fans
would definitely freak out if this were
to happen
so let me know what you think about this
in the comments down below would you
absolutely freak out if you saw this
happen
be sure to let me know in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest
mcu news for other giveaways you can
follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you